alright so you guys know that i love the
future stories i love the robot stories
i love technology stories yes robots are
coming to destroy this and that's why i
do it so that years from now on a crack
TV screen in a room after the robotic
overtake you'll see this and people
though he knew what he was saying anyway
I saw this interesting story out of Hong
Kong about how they're dealing with
litterbugs take a look
well that's only possible by collecting
DNA from little found on the streets
scientists then use it to predict face
shape as well as eye and hair color from
the samples you can see on the screen
compositor the pictures are recreated
from cigarette butts face masks and even
chewing gum as well once people are ID'd
the faces of the little bugs are
displayed on most wanted posters across
Hong Kong man it really seems like every
week we do another story that makes me
feel like we're actually in the matrix
right now before we go forward though we
got a quote from the co-founder of the
project it was wonderful to use such new
and innovative technology to promote a
message that's quite important for this
region the campaign is intended to
provoke thought discussion of our waste
habits on littering but also just on how
much we throw away and what we consume
on the daily basis so of course this is
really cool because this is technology
being used for good right I do all the
stories on technology and how can maybe
be used for babba This Is It this is a
good one they've got a litter problem
and they're going to shame people into
just throwing their litter in the trash
which is usually just like half a block
away from wherever you're standing so
the part of this of course that's scary
is that we do live in a time when the
NSA and all kinds of other governments
Secret Service agents are watching
people you know drones and cameras
everywhere and phones and GPS and all
that and that this is just seemingly
another way of you know your DNA getting
out there literally that they could
recreate your face and your facial
features by picking up a piece of gum
that you threw on the floor so I do
think there's some risk that some bad
stuff could come out of this but
generally I think and you know this is
the slippery slope argument like here's
a good idea but where does this go does
the government have right to pick up
trash that you threw on the floor and
then find your DNA strands from it I
don't know I don't know it's it's an
interesting debate i should get neil
tyson neil degrasse tyson on here to
talk about it anyway i'm curious to know
what you guys think about
so let me know in the comments right now